[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand elle a été créée en fête au centre
de nanosciences et des nanotechnologies
des universités paris saclay et du cnrs
et donc nous sommes basés sur le plateau
de saclay et nous développons des
ordinateurs un peu spéciaux qu'on
appelle des ordinateurs quantiques qui
sont des ordinateurs qui vont utiliser
toutes les propriétés de la matière de
la mécanique quantique pour développer
de nouvelles techniques de calcul très
puissante le 21 janvier dernier nous
avons reçu le président de la république
emmanuel macron dans nos locaux au
centre de l'océan ces nanotechnologies
où il a annoncé l'ambition française
autour du plan quantique nationale
l'ambition de la france vise à
développer
justement toute cette technologie autour
des ordinateurs quantiques autour des
communications et des capteurs quantique
est donc aujourd'hui les grands
instituts comme le cnrs l'université
paris saclay l'inria le cea et les
startups comme candela s'organisent pour
mettre en action leurs ambitions
nationales autour du plan quantique
annoncée par le président est donc en
gros la france va investir 1,8 milliard
d'euros pour financer cette ambition
française financer le passage des
briques technologiques qui sont encore
des laboratoires de recherche comme au
sein de l'université paris saclay vers
des applications et c'est exactement ce
que nous faisons chez candela nous
valorisons une technologie qui était
développée au cnrs et université paris
saclay dans le centre de nanosciences et
nanotechnologies pour développer des
ordinateurs quantiques
c'est donc ici en fait on a développé un
premier prototype qui sert à faire des
premiers calculs à partir de quelques
cubique c'est cubique
ce sont en fait des particules de
lumière qu'on appelle des photons donc
c'est vraiment le grain alimentaire de
la lumière et on utilise le photon pour
enregistrer de l'information quantique
dessus et faire des calculs avec
candela est maintenant en train de
suivre un virage nous cherchons à lever
des fonds pour ça qu'on a fait la une de
challenge afin d'augmenter nos équipes
et d'aller plus loin dans le
développement d'un ordinateur quantique
à base de photos notre ambition c'est de
sortir un ordinateur utile avec
plusieurs dizaines de cuite d'ici trois
à quatre ans elle le met sur le marché
en version cloud ou directement chez les
clients
[Musique]